[Music]
[Music]
she would have thought
two years was enough time for the
strangeness to rub off but it wasn't
[Music]
julianne moore is an amazingly
talented actress she's an academy
award-winning actress
and when she expressed enthusiasm
for the story and the scripts i was just
overjoyed i was over the moon
julian is so powerful she has
not only a very particular beauty but
it's someone can
that can hold an enormous amount of
mystery
and i think when you work with materials
like this where mystery suspense
fantasy thriller you know they're all
mixed and combined in this
sort of explosion of memories
someone like julian can really hold it
and put it together it's a hugely
challenging part because she's playing
somebody who's
full of grief and full of pain and often
under threat
in the thing so it's a very sort of
heightened
state she's in throughout
time apparently did nothing but blunt
grief's sharpest edge
so that it hacked rather than sliced
[Music]
you